we give you the example of Mexico they
have a vat tax we're in a different
system when we sell into Mexico there's
a tax when they sell it automatic
sixteen percent approximately when they
sell into us there's no tax it's a
defective agreement
we're losing how a good job so many of
them so Ford is leaving you see that
their small car division leaving
thousands of jobs leaving Michigan
leaving Ohio they're all leaving
you
maybe he doesn't want the American
people all of you watching tonight to
know that he's paid nothing in federal
taxes because the only years that
anybody's ever seen we're a couple of
years when he had to turn them over to
state authorities when he was trying to
get a casino license and they showed he
didn't pay any federal income tax so
that makes me sorry
you had supported the war in Iraq before
the invasion what makes sure i did not
support a war in iraq i was against the
war in iraq just so you put it at the
record tonight other whatever why not
you why was your depression shows that
I'm right Donald supported the invasion
of Iraq wrong that is absolute wrong
move over and over again
for you for invading Iraq yeah I guess
so you know I wish it was I wish the
first stop it was done correctly